um you know first question TV so much
has been written of course about Steve
Jobs so much has been said about him how
involved was he really in the overall
look of the stores Steve would be
involved in everything yeah and those
are the greatest clients because in a
way you're trying to get it their nature
in their heart yeah I mean the so first
night when you first met him I knew did
he say this is my vision this is what I
want to do did you guys work together on
that how did it evolve we first met him
that at Pixar and he hired us to do
Pixar and he said I've hired you I'm
paraphrasing because Peter you do really
good launch Billings do great houses now
who else but Steve Jobs would say that
you think that yeah I mean so the whole
glass uh look to the Apple stores was
that him
no I think it was all of us and I
certainly was right in the middle
mm-hmm was she looking to it and how the
firm was you know Chen your firm was is
well sure yeah
did you or did you set out to Josh who
was so Pope uh-huh and it was the first
two storey store you know the Apple you
know the is in the old post office down
there and so how do you get people to go
up that's a great challenge in retail
and we made a glass tear that was the
first one yeah yeah I mean what um what
was the goal what were you setting out
to do genomic I got some a place that
was very much in the nature of pepper
I guess you Michael that Brandon I've
never quite used that term but the same
thing in architecture can be part of
Brandon chirping she would certainly for
the Apple what yes how is it different
say I know you've been involved with a
number of sort of tech pioneers how did
Steve Jobs differ from some of the other
people that you've worked with
everyone is different it's amazing you
know as we all are different and you
really have to get it at that if you
don't you're not gonna do your job right
you're not gonna get it right I know
that you've worked with Jack Dorsey um
it was a great treat by the way yeah I
like him so much
really yes what do you like about him he
sort of laid-back smart laid-back is he
very involved in the process LSD jobs
not in the same way Steve Steve would be
sort of overarching but certainly
chuckles um so it didn't square that
that you helped to build their
headquarters yes
um how would you characterize we did
again I should always say that about my
cohorts yes uh although I was caught
involved um
square um you know what we're gonna do
about one floor a year four square in an
old building new old building from the
70s well and it's going to be it's going
to be square which means it's it's very
quite interactive and quite open and
quite delicate um what were the
challenges that you had to overcome when
you were build
our headquarters any any challenges you
had to overcome when you were building
their headquarters um well one was
budget you know yours would have to get
right it was always the big dealer yeah
and then you'd better make an image
schedule you know all of that but on the
end just to get it right all right and
get it right in the truths for Jack